who knew a cord light could be a
stand-in for magic spells doctor strange
has dazzled in every one of his
appearances in the mcu and it's in big
part thanks to the help of cgi
cg was almost always necessary but how
did they do it we've got the raw footage
from 20 doctor strange scenes without
cgi coming right up
number one the consequences can be
pretty catastrophic doctor strange
casting the spell in no way home and
inadvertently causing total chaos in the
multiverse didn't look quite so exciting
without the vfx that being said the
ancient chamber that the team
constructed in atlanta certainly did the
trick in setting the right tone while
the really dazzling magic had to wait
until the vfx stage the set design team
made sure to bring as much of the magic
into the space including preset
practical lights this went off in a
similar fashion to the magic we'd see as
well as practical set pieces allowing
holland and cover batch to really
immerse themselves in the world to amp
up the excitement the two actors were
also rigged up to wires letting cg hide
those ropes in the final cut while
safely allowing the actors to experience
that bit of movie-making magic
number two
you'd think he could heat the place
somehow you never know exactly what
you're walking into when you go to the
sanctum sanctorum the snow all over the
set was white and powdery as could be
but there was one unusual aspect to it
the white powder decorating every inch
of the set was super salty
all that convincing set dressing was
actually epsom salts which really felt
like stepping through slushy snow for
the actors on set while it wasn't real
it did still cause the actors to slip a
bit while filming extra effects to boost
the chill factor came into play
afterwards with some cg layering
number three
dr strange was really regretting his
offer to help peter now the problem with
trying to reason with a teenager is well
the fact that they're a teenager the
fact that this chase was happening
through the mirror dimension meant the
battle had to be filmed in multiple
parts sets varying for each moment
strange was getting way more of a
workout than he'd anticipated in some
instances cumberbatch had to be rigged
up to wires to help him as he leapt and
chased after peter parker was really
getting on his last nerve by this point
number four he could fly he could cast
spells he could travel through spaces
that made no sense doctor strange was
really living his best life on screen
and behind the scenes in front of the
blue screen cumberbatch was doing the
same there were multiple setups for the
actor to film each section from wires to
hold him horizontally to floating in the
air to casting spells in his battle with
peter the spaces were sparse but the cg
bringing the multiple different places
we see on screen brings us to a chaotic
world the fact that parker did last this
long in the chase is extra impressive
number five
when strange enters a space you know it
seriously how much more regal can he get
the elegant descent onto the ground was
thanks to the doctor strange actors
natural grace and harnesses the blue
screen background did the trick allowing
the big end-game battlefield to be
brought to life
the shot just can't help but be epic
considering all the actors that are
together on screen but it is way more
dazzling when we actually see doctor
strange coming through a portal who
doesn't love a good portal
number six make way for the avengers
swagger this crew was looking cool as
could be filming in the midst of real
rubble and mini fires all around talk
about high stakes brutal as the shot
looks it's still an epic one all the
same considering who's in this crew it's
a shot that captures the chaos of
infinity war pretty well
number seven
now this was a fight you'd want front
row tickets for one of the biggest and
most exciting fights in marvel history
at the time saw the production pulling
out all the stops we're talking wires
giant green backdrops in major sound
stages and benedict cumberbatch's
signature magic making hand gestures
when it came time to strange and spidey
duking it out multiple factors were at
play helping to control the rigging and
capturing every detail
number eight welcome to a new edition of
is it a real place or is it a set the
answer is another incredibly realistic
set from the marvel team the extensive
details allowed the actors to completely
immerse themselves in the world of the
story but cg was still key in hiding the
movie magic in the final cut without
those harnesses in sight the actors
could pull off all their stunt choreo
flawlessly
on top of the images captured the vfx
team brought the scene to the next level
with all that light and dazzle we've
grown to love in the doctor strange
films
number nine
we're about to get upside down
at least at some point while spinning
around in the nauseating corridor
shockingly this was a very practically
shot bit unfortunate for benedict
cumberbatch who had to deal with the
unstable ground beneath him the whole
time the walls inside the large
structure were made of rubber making for
a cushier material to work with and a
bit safer for cumberbatch to pull the
stunts off
number 10 get ready for an epic scene on
set the training grounds were full of
energy rhythm and heat the main
difference really was that they were in
a studio
they were working in front of green
screens and practically built set pieces
that established different landmarks and
structures in the scene for the actors
with the help of cg the delicate and
intricate magical light detailing has
been expertly done since the very first
doctor strange
number 11
is it a city or a set or both the team
really did spend some time filming in
kathmandu but after that was wrapped
they built their own version to continue
filming on and this replica was oh so
convincing
cumberbatch essentially had the real
city visually with the control and
functionality of a film set really just
the best of both worlds the team didn't
just stop at the recreated set though to
help transport them to kathmandu incense
was lit to bring the scents and essences
of the city to the filming studio
number 12.
yet another common household item that
couldn't be magical if used in the right
way who knew a cord light could be so
effective it was the perfect stand-in to
allow benedict cumberbatch to battle in
style while gaining a bit of that magic
glow only to go full out with the vfx in
post
number 13.
is this not one of the coolest ways to
travel in the mcu get through the portal
or as they like to call it on set the
giant circle light
the actors got to experience going
through some kind of portal the stand in
light and ramps on set were similar
enough in structure at least just like
in the movies though there is never just
one portal the giant circle of light had
different spaces depending on what was
being filmed with the classic green
screen backdrop to fill in until vfx
brought the appropriate images to the
screen
number 14 who needs solid ground anyway
the mirror dimension chaos is never fun
so luckily the doctor strange actor
wasn't really enduring the hardships of
the ever-shifting environment getting to
keep his feet firmly planted on the
ground it was his cg double who took on
the hard work falling through the
chaotic and confusing space animated
cape and all
number 15. need a cape get a cape when
doctor strange asks for a cape you give
him a cape
the cg team was ready with a cg model of
it seemingly flowing and floating so
cumberbatch could mime grabbing it from
anywhere around him and then with a bit
of vfx magic voila cape anywhere anytime
the cape itself flows so well in part
because of the detailed cg weaving all
the connection points in the animation
allow for lifelike and subtle movements
that convince us what we're watching is
actually an always magical looking cape
that would automatically ripple in the
wind wherever it was
number 16
leave it to the computers and nobody
gets hurt honestly it's not a bad idea
we're surprised this doesn't happen more
often to pull off the most intense and
mystical of battles the best solution
was to let the computers take over the
cgi animators took center stage
designing and animating the characters
and building the scene from the previz
stage all the way to the final sleek
looking images we see this was the most
realistic way to accurately capture the
breaking of the conventions of space
number 17
how many doctor strangers can there be
in one frame in order to convincingly
pull his soul out of his body leaving us
with a kind of translucent doctor the cg
game here had to be strong multiple
versions of strange caught in a moment
floating through space were made up
bringing a ghostly yet very realistic
looking doctor then it was all up to the
cg version of the actor who was animated
to glide effortlessly in front of blue
screens and practical sets benedict
cumberbatch did take over once his
character was settled on screen but a
layer of special effects was added to
bring the ghostlier vibes to life
number 18
sometimes it's the cgi dock that's
needed on set and considering just how
realistic and detailed the cg version of
this doctor strange is it's no wonder
the cg team is responsible for full
sequences from the surroundings to the
cave to the body to the face
digital creation based entirely on the
actor himself cgi was responsible for
building this whole frame using real
footage of cumberbatch hooked up in
harnesses as a reference to work from
plenty of character studies and photos
were captured to render the cg dock and
the translation from inspiration to the
final cut it's as good as it gets
number 19.
to be honest when doctor strange is
around when isn't the world feeling
topsy-turvy which world are we in and
where are we it's never too easy to tell
but fortunately for benedict cumberbatch
the experience wasn't quite as
discombobulating as it was for the
viewers watching it his filming world
the land of the green screen his
imagination was hard at work and so was
he
number 20 these imaginations have got to
be real creative sometimes our breath is
taken away seeing some of the landscapes
in the movies of the mcu but the most
typical scene the actors see green or
blue screens would always do the trick
in keeping the background clean enough
so the cg team could bring these
brilliant worlds to life while the
scenes before the cgi is added aren't
nearly as fascinating visually they are
pretty innovative and creative typically
making for an ideal environment for the
performers on set which practically
built set were you most surprised by